[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وعلى بركه الله
افتتاح الدوره الثانيه والثلاثون لمجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى القمه
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسمو والعميل العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه
الحضور الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته يسرني ان ارحب بكم في بلدكم
الثاني مملكه العربيه السعوديه ونرحب بضيف
القمه فخامه
الرئيسكي رئيس اوكرانيا ونامل ان تتكلل
جهودنا بالتوفيق والنجاح كما يسرني ان
اشكر فخامه الرئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه عبد المجيد تبون على
الجهود المبذوله خلال تراس بلاده للدوره
السابقه ونشكر معالي الامين العام لجامعه
الدول العربيه وجميع العاملين فيها على
مبادلوا من جهود لخدمه العمل العربي
المشترك
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو نؤكد لدول
الجوار والاصدقاء في الغرب والشرقون
للسلام والخير والتعاون والبناء بما يحقق
مصالح شعوبنا ويصون حقوق امتنا واننا لن
نسمح بل تتحول منطقتنا ميدان للصراعات
ويكفينا طي صفحه الماضي
تذكر سنوات مؤلمه من الصراعات عاشتها
المنطقه وعانت منها شعوبها وتعثرت بسببها
مسيره التنميه
وهم يسرنا اليوم حضور فخامه الرئيس بشار
الاسد لهذه القمه وصدور قرار جامعه الدول
العربيه بشان استئناف مشاركه وفود الحكومه
السوريه في اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه ونامل ان يسهم ذلك في دعم استقرار
سوريا وعوده الامور لطبيعتها واستئناف
دورها الطبيعي في الوطن العربي بما يحقق
الخير لشعبها وما يدعم تطلعاتنا جميعا نحو
المستقبل افضل لمنطقتنا الحضور الكرام من
القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت ولا زالت هي قضيه
العرب والمسلمين المحوريه
وتاتي على راس اولويات السياسات المملكه
الخارجيه ولم تتوانى المملكه وتتاخر في
دعم الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق لاسترجاع
اراضيه واستعاده حقوقه المشروعه واقامه
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله ذات سياده على اراضي
الفلسطينيه بحدود عام 67 وعاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه
وفقا لقارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
السلام العربيه وغيرها من المرجعيات
الدوليه المتفق عليها بما يحقق مطلعات
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق
ان شقاق في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يكرسون جهودهم في دعم القضايا العربيه كما
نعمل على مساعده اطراف اليمنيه للوصول الى
حل سياسي شامل ينهي الازمه اليمني وفيما
يخص السويدان نامل ان تكون لغه الحوار هي
الاساس للحفظ على وحده السودان وامن شعبه
مقدراته وفي هذا الصدد فان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ترحب بتوقيع طرفي نزاع
على اعلان جده الالتزام بحمايه مدنيين
وتسهيل العمل الانساني ونامل التركيز خلال
هذه المحادثات على وقف فعال لاطلاق النار
تواصل المملكه بالتعاون مع الاشقاء
والاصدقاء والمجتمع الدولي
[موسيقى]
بذل الجهود الانسانيه وتفعيل قنوات
الاغاثه للشعب السوداني الشقيق ويطيب لنا
ان ننتهز هذه الفرصه بوجود فخامه الرئيس
ايلينسكي رئيس اوكرانيا ومشاركه هذه القمه
المجدد تاكيد موقف المملكه الداعم لكل ما
يسهم في خفض حده الازمه في اوكرانيا وعدم
تدهور الاوضاع الانسانيه واستعاده المملكه
واستعداد المملكه الاستمرار في بدل الجهود
الوساطه بين روسيا الاتحاديه واوكرانيا
ودعم جميع الجهود الدوليه للراميه الى حل
الازمه السياسيا بما يرسم في تحقيق الامن
والسلم الحضور الكرام انه وطننا العربي
يملك من المقومات الحضريه والثقافيه
والموارد البشريه والطبيعيه ما يؤهل لتبني
مكانه متقدمه وقياديه وتحقيق نهضه شامله
لدولنا في جميع المجالات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]